welcome to the news uh let's bring you
some breaking news coming out of Iran
where dozens of school girls across five
provinces are in hospital after a new
wave of suspected poisoning attacks on
Friday president ibrahimraisi blamed the
attacks on Iran's enemies Let's cross
over to our correspondent dorsa Jabara
who's in Tehran Forest now and also what
do we know about these latest attacks
and where they happened
well according to human rights groups
inside the country there has been at
least 40 attacks in various parts of
Iran not limited to any specific
Province we have seen footage emerging
from various schools and universities
where we see girls being taken out on
stretchers to hospitals they have
difficulty breathing and they're clearly
distraught according to semi-official
news agencies there have been at least a
dozen attacks taking place on Saturday
alone at various parts of the country
where girls have been attacked while
they were studying in classroom this is
certainly an escalation over what we've
seen in the story in the past week and
it's something that has been ongoing in
Iran since November but over the past 10
days or so these attacks have certainly
increased not only in numbers but also
in locations across Iran not limited to
certain provinces we've seen in a number
of attacks on Wednesday alone there were
10 schools in Tehran alone that were
attacked and we saw a number of victims
being taken to hospital
of course the authorities have said that
it's Iran's enemies are behind this but
that's pretty vague in itself are they
being any clearer about where the finger
of blame is being pointed
no for right now there is no clear
answer being provided by any officials
in government we heard from the Iranian
president ibrahimraisi during his speech
on Friday he accused Western powers of
carrying out these attacks to try and
create instability in Iran and to try to
create fear amongst the parents of these
girls of school girls in general in the
country we know that the president has
tasked the interior minister to look
into at these attacks and also trying to
figure out what is happening and to
prevent them from taking place we
understand that the various levels of
intelligence apparatuses in the country
are also working with the interior
Ministry but I think it's important to
point out that we don't have any clear
answers and the officials haven't
provided any evidence that they've come
up with that would prove Western powers
to be involved or foreign powers to be
involved in these attacks what is clear
is that they are increasing in numbers
which is only making parents more
worried I've spoken to a number parents
over the past few hours who say they're
clearly worried about their daughters
and they're not sure if they will send
them back to school in the coming days
we also saw a number of parents whose
daughters were taken to hospital they
were outside the interior Ministry
earlier in the capital trying to demand
answers from officials and reports came
back that they were taken away from that
area not allowed to demonstrate so it is
certainly the issue is escalating and
the attacks are increasing which is only
creating more fear amongst the public
you said that these attacks had begun in
November in an ad hoc fashion around the
country in different provinces and hard
to actually see a pattern per se so what
of the authorities what advice have the
authorities given to schools and
educational authorities in various
provinces about taking precautions
well we haven't heard any specific
instructions from officials and that is
one of the points of contention amongst
parents how schools here operate in
general if there are public schools they
do have most of them security cameras
installed at various points outside
around the parameters of the schools and
inside them as well and what is creating
frustration amongst the parents is since
the first case was reported back in
November in the city of home the
authorities did not take the um
parents concerns that seriously it was
only over the past week that officials
got involved because they saw these
increased attacks taking place
um the parents are saying how could the
officials have no leads or no answers
for us as to how to prevent these
attacks from taking place as to how the
government is planning on protecting
these girls better in the coming days
while they go through the school year I
think it's important also to highlight
that the officials are saying that they
don't want panic and fear to be
increased amongst their parents but
clearly as these attacks continue and
their failure to do anything about them
is making those parents just more
worried as we go through these days and
we also understand the speaker of
parliament khalib off is all holding a
meeting with various heads of different
committees in Parliament we're waiting
to find out what they will come up with
as to their recommendations we'll
continue to follow this story in the
coming hours Joseph correspondent for us
in Tehran